[Musique]
de plaine en forêt de vallon en colline
du printemps qui va naître à des modes
saison
de ce que j'ai vécu à ce que j'imagine
je n'en finirais pas décrire ta chanson
m'a fort en ce
[Musique]
grand soleil d'été qui courbent la
provence
des genêts de bretagne aux bruyères
d'ardèche
quelque chose dans l'air à cette
transparence et ce goût du bonheur qui
rend ma lèvre st
je pense
cet air de liberté au delà des
frontières
aux peuples étrangers qui donnait le
vertige
et dont vous usurpez aujourd'hui le
prestige elle répond toujours du nom de
robespierre ma france
celle du vieil hugo tonnant de son exil
les enfants de 5 ans travaillant dans
les mines
[Musique]
celle qui construisit de ses mains vos
usines salo dont monsieur thiers a dit
on l'a fusil
[Musique]
picasso tient de monde au bout de sa
palette
[Musique]
des lèvres d'eluard s'envoler des
colombes
il n'en finissent pas fait artistes bros
fait de dire qu'il est temps que le
malheur succombe ma faute
danse
[Musique]
leurs voix se multiplient à ne plus
faire reculer
c'est le clip est toujours grimm à 20
heures
on remplit son histoire et ses fosses
communes je chante à jamais celle des
travailleurs
à la france
[Musique]
celle qui ne possède en or que ses nuits
blanches
pour la lutte obstinée de ce tango dire
du journal que l'on vende matin dimanche
à l'affiché contre nommé dublin 2 ah bon
en ce
elles montrent des mines
mais sol et des gros vim
c'est lui qui chante en moi la belle la
rebelle
elle tient à venir serrer dans ses mains
fils celle de 3,6 à 68 chandelle
avant ce
[Musique]